[Music]
so I work on trying to understand how
the universe works at the very basic
level the most basic level we can find
so when you try in your everyday life to
try and work out how something works
what you're actually doing is you're
looking for what I call hidden
structures for example you take
something like your cell phone your
smartphone there's a complicated object
and you might wonder how it works well
what you can do is go in and actually
take it apart you'll void the warranty
but that's okay
and you go in and what you find is that
it's made of tiny little electronic
components and those electronic
components are actually moving around a
certain kind of particle we know that's
called the electron and that's where the
name of that Tronics comes from so if
you know the actual rules of how to put
those things together you can actually
make your smart phone or you could make
various other electronic devices as well
so there are people like myself who
actually for a living
try and do this sort of thing not just
for say a cell phone or its components
but asking what's a your hand is made of
or the chair you're sitting in or the
planet Earth the Sun the Stars the
entire universe and so using various
kinds of instruments and observations
and experiments we've been able to prou
deeper and deeper over the years and we
now know that the matter that we're made
of and that we see around us is actually
made of tiny little elementary particles
and elementary particles interact with
each other via the forces of nature but
we've also discovered that those forces
of nature themselves actually operate by
exchanging elementary particles as well
they're actually particles of force that
are exchanged by the particles of matter
and you may have heard this year that
there was big news a major announcement
in this story that Large Hadron Collider
the LHC a huge experiment in Europe has
actually uncovered a Higgs boson and
that particles job is to interact with
the various elementary particles and
give them the masses that we observe so
this exciting picture is analogous to
the one I showed you for the cell phone
we have the components and we have the
rules
of particle theory as its called by
which eezol operate and give rise to the
various things now we actually think
that we've only just scratched the
surface of finding this quantum world
the hidden structure of our world let me
give you three examples of the puzzles
we're still working on so what I did is
I gathered the particles up into the
patterns that they tend to form and we
don't know where those patterns come
from we know how to describe the
particles but we don't know where the
patterns come from when you see patterns
and science you look for a hidden
structure so that's one of the things
also we now know that there's a huge
amount more matter out there than just
the things that I was just talking about
that stuff is called dark matter we
don't know what it is and we'd like to
be able to get it and experiment with it
and figure out what it is and then the
other thing I'd like to tell you about
is the fact that the force of gravity
perhaps the most familiar force we know
when you get down to the quantum level
it actually doesn't operate according to
those rules of particle theory so given
that gravity is actually about the shape
of space and time as Einstein taught us
we in working out what the quantum story
of gravity is which we call quantum
gravity we hope to get to grips and
questions like are there particles of
space and time itself and how do they
fit together what are the rules so this
leads us to things like studying where
it all began 13.7 billion years ago the
Big Bang we know matter and energy as we
understand it was created but also space
and time itself so those are the sorts
of things we study in this quest also we
have things that are around us today
such as black holes which are very
important clues they're actual holes in
space that we'd like to actually
understand also the newly discovered
dark energy which is the tendency of
space all through the universe to
accelerate its expansion so scientists
are working on these kinds of things
trying to understand what we think is
now the case that there's not just
hidden structures of matter and energy
but also space and time so the question
is what are the rules and then many
approaches to this and one of them is
one that you may have heard are called
string theory and so it's one of many
approaches and we don't know if it's
right yet we've not finished developing
the theory but it's given us some really
exciting tantalizing hints
like to tell you about a few of them so
one of them is simply that you take away
the idea of looking for a tiny quantum
of particle you look instead for an
extended object a string which can
vibrate and that actually gives you some
exciting opportunities because for
example it would say if we've missed
that hidden structure but not looking
closely enough we wouldn't realize that
many different kinds of particles are
just different vibrations of the same
string which is a really exciting
possibility and a huge simplification so
that's one of the ideas the other thing
that's really exciting about string
theory is that one of those particles
that describes is actually the missing
quantum of gravity that we've been
trying to understand and then the other
thing is that strings actually instead
of wanting just to move in the
dimensions the three space dimensions
that we're familiar with actually seem
to want to move in higher dimensions so
we have this idea then what would it
mean for our world if this were anything
to do with our world and we don't know
that yet here's a way that our world
would arise from that you would have our
world and then one of the hidden
structures would be hidden chunks of
space-time that are that are not visible
those extra dimensions and then the
various particles that we see in the
world will come from being vibrations of
strings and those patterns we saw that
we can't explain
come from the fact that the strings can
probe and feel the shape of those
internal dimensions so one of the things
that is can we actually test this is
lovely idea but how do we confront this
with real experiments and observations
because we're doing science here and
that's the hard thing we think that the
energy you need to prove the tiny enough
scales to see the strings if they're
there is more than we can hope to get
anytime soon but what we can do is we
can look for the consequences of those
hidden structures we can look for how
those things show up in physics that we
can get access to so that's why we study
things like dark matter black holes dark
energy and we also look remnants of the
early universe the Cosmic Microwave
Background with satellites and
importantly we look for clues from the
various kinds of particle physics
experiments like the LHC so one last
thing then is new
thing that's been going on string theory
may turn out to be useful in other areas
of physics there new kinds of
experiments that start out say with our
friends the electron and actually show
that in certain circumstances the
electrons interact in a way that gives
you completely new weird kinds of
behavior and they're models that show
that string theory is actually the best
way in some circumstances using the
rules of string theory you can actually
explain that sort of behavior so this
gives this exciting possibility that
it's real experiments you can do with
these electrons that'll help us shape
the rules for what string theory is and
you might go well okay that's going to
give us maybe some fancy new kind of
electronics that we can make a better
cell phone with but I'm saying that
those rules may actually be the same
rules we're looking for to see if string
theory can help us with these bigger
questions so at the end of the day the
hidden structures of the universe we're
looking for may one day be right under
our noses thank you
[Applause]